ok we are hot
we chain
changes in work and employment
so let's go in introduction
it is said that from the nineteenth century
working conditions
were rough
and wages were very low
after numerous strikes and demonstrations
the workers get
many more rights
for better working conditions
one of the consequences
is that the role of the unions
was thus recognized
by law on March 21,
more in 1945
we see
the development of social security
so basically
the relationship established today between
business leaders and employees
result from these numerous developments
of the last few years
allowing
today to become an employee
a guarantee of safety
also
you have to make the difference between a job
and-a job
a job corresponds to the position held
and work
it's the task
to be exercised in bulk
for an intermarket cashier for example
his job is to work at Intermarché
his job is to page the articles
all day
then you have to make a difference
between the active population
and the inactive population
the active population
includes all persons
who report employment
or are actively looking for a
because yes
from the time a person has been a job
and currently unemployed
she is considered an active person
it is considered as
a person who is actively seeking
a new job
and then we
a the inactive population
which includes all the people
who cannot legally work
such as minors for example
and those who
so they also give up having one
so there is a little
what is called a blurring of borders
today the boundaries between unemployment
inactivity and employment
are less and less marked
for the last few years
due to the increase in situations
intermediaries
because yes
it is important to know that there are two forms of use
atypical jobs
it's part-time jobs
like the cdd
or a seasonal precarious job,
etc.
and we have the atypical jobs
it's all cdi
permanent contracts
also it is necessary to know
that some people find themselves
at the crossroads of employment and inactivity
we call it the halo of unemployment
this halo of unemployment
concerns people
unemployed who would like to work
and who therefore
are not classified as unemployed
and this halo of unemployment concerns 1
6 1,000,000 people
then there is a big difference to make
between the quality of employment
and the amount of time worked
today
studies show that the measurement
the quality of the job
matters as much as its quantity
from the .
of view of the workers
whether compensation is an essential factor
other elements related to quality of life
and well-being are also taken into account
finish what a strict hierarchy is
it is simply in a company a
desire for a higher return
in ever shorter time
employees are thus timed
controlled and all strolling is forbidden
and this is where we saw the implementation
of remuneration by performance
that is,
you get paid for what you did
and then we see the appearance of a new model
which is the post-lorian model
and I'll tell you about it in part 2